shot-clock already down to five finally
gives it up Derrick Rose straight away
looking at triple Kansas he gets going
to be you know a challenge for Derrick
Rose now one thing I was looking forward
to is he takes you to go bare right to
the right what a finished by d-rose get
to where he wants to
it's a second time Derrick rook Rose
fires away and hits it
Dirk's done a nice job of getting better
arcing shot he'll need a and then
Mitchell and that Corona 8-ounce comes
over and helps alter the shot
Minnesota's shot blocking has gotten so
much better
Browns top shell but he makes the shot
anyway that's the temples apply the will
to the Utah Jazz here tonight and they
start the third quarter on a high note
as Derrick Rose pushes it back up to an
11 point lead Rose attacks challenges go
bare and go bare couldn't get there in
time also not being able to get back out
to cover in these first two sisters the
night for Gobert Rose continuing to
attack rudy gobert with success
interesting Jim that's at Jazz and the
temple walls say walking to beat again
until the new year
2:27
[Applause]
great screen by Taj Gibson fantastic
screen the angle of it set perfect
though lovely I need more cowbell but
the anchorman as well too Derrick Rose
just keeps
towns no problem with some footwork on
that one drilling the triple ops to the
Warriors way the two poles all fences
Roland's they've got a chance to cook
that here that kryptonite shot clock
down to five Rose who at 19 in the third
quarter has his first points of the
fourth quarter
Rose out of the corner to do for the
Timberwolves and you see the emotion on
Derrick Rose's face a 50 point effort to
get the Timberwolves a gutty win over
the Utah Jazz he's got a lot stuff going
on off the court and I'm not a judge and
I'm not